I Samuel leaves here I hope you had a
fantastic week happy Monday and thank
God I'm back in England if you watch my
video last week you're saying about how
I was dying in the Ugandan hospital so
I'm gonna be sharing a little bit about
what happened in this video but most
importantly I'm going to be talking
about what videos we've got coming up
and also sharing some ideas and thoughts
around the financial freedom challenge
which is still happening despite this
leg so stay tuned so firstly what
happened to me I don't want to spend too
long talking about it I know this is a
property channel but effectively I went
out to Uganda I go out to Africa it once
or twice a year to do charity work so
I've brought a team out with me we have
some of our top students my brother some
guides and before we went out on the
field to do our charity work we always
have a team-building exercise and in
this case it was water rafting and water
rafting is not a dangerous sport very
few people get injured but we had a
freak accident whereby the boat capsized
and we all fell down a waterfall several
waterfalls and we weren't in a boat
which is quite dangerous really so a few
people got cuts and bruises I've got a
really badly broken knee buying my head
and was in hospital in Uganda for eight
days and although the hospital looked
after me and everything like that really
I needed to be home because the
hospitals in Uganda are not like the
ones in England and after the accident I
needed to be home so after a lot of
fighting and phone calls and messing
around I finally managed to get home
it's very difficult to get out to get an
airline to take you when you're in a big
leg cast in you're sick so thank God
we've got a property business where
we're making a passive income because
while I'm in the hospital bed completely
helpless I know that my wife has got an
income coming in I know that I'm able to
book a private jet if I need to because
we've got the finance and funds to do
that so it's you know having a property
business not only does it enable you to
have fun and they're going to enable you
to live a really
good life but also when the going gets
tough and when it crap hits the fan also
money is able to really help you get out
of a lot of mess which it did and so did
people and friends and thank you for
your support but my ticket cost a lot it
cost me ten thousand pounds to get back
as commercial flights just because I
needed to book so many seats because I'm
like conditioned got home a few days ago
just been recently dismissed from the
English hospital so right now my
condition is I've got nothing serious
I've got a badly broken knee I might
need an operation on it again
and I'm now I'm now in a cast so I think
the lesson from all of this was warm as
I said before financial freedom is
really important because it gets you out
of next net sometimes and really works
as insurance but listen to is when you
feel like life is just absolutely awful
it always gets better so when I was
lying there in Uganda after falling down
the waterfall being in shock happened to
them got up all the team with a broken
knee and I mean I'm in hospital and
they're saying to me your eyes and red
but concerned but we haven't got any
machines that work to scan your head
I've got English doctors saying we might
have to operate on your leg again God
we're going crazy saying come home and I
can't get home you know he's a baker's
dark place but I knew that you know
where wherever there's a dark place
there's always there's always a ray of
sunlight bursting through the clouds
there's always hope and now just a week
or two later Here I am so things always
get better so if you're in a bad place
right now things are gonna get a lot
better
so updates about this YouTube channel
firstly so I absolutely love this
YouTube channel and I love my YouTube
followers and fans and your comments and
your love and support really is my
oxygen and seeing the success results of
people just off the back of the YouTube
video in fact those are lady that I took
out to Africa with me last week she
ended up she was doing loads of great
stuff she met I booked her a dinner she
had a dinner with Robert Kiyosaki
unfortunately I wasn't able to be there
but she got started and but I bought her
first two
just off the back of the YouTube channel
you know I met her at the crash course
and she said I've already got two hours
later said okay cool
she said I said where did you get their
knowledge to get them to because they
look like really good houses she said
ball from your YouTube channel so I
really love this youtube channel and
even though I'm feeling a little bit
rough at the moment and I'm in a cast
and things like that
luckily me and Nick my my videographer
who manages the YouTube channel we did
have that we've got a backlog of some
really good videos around lease option
agreements buying houses have no money
Power Team some just and some fabulous
indonesia's well with some absolute key
experts some students that have become
financially free within a matter of two
or three months can you believe that
so some incredible interviews and some
content which we've got so Nick's gonna
edit that and put that out there over
the next few weeks while I rest my leg
also the financial freedom challenge I
put a video recently a few weeks back
about I crave the idea of me becoming
financially free all over again starting
with nothing and building everything up
from scratch and filming it and the
response was massively overwhelming
people said you know what if you can do
it again and you can film it starting
with nothing then that would that would
really inspire us and take away our
excuses so I've decided that I'm gonna
do the challenge I'm gonna do the
challenge and I'm gonna do it soon and
I'm not necessarily gonna wait for my
leg to recover either because I think
doing it in crutches would even add to
the power and the absolute no excuses so
I'm gonna do the challenge we're gonna
keep the channel going I've got some
really cool videos come in so please do
keep engaged with the channel keep
liking keep subscribing keep sharing
thank you for your love also I'm gonna
be running a crash course as well I've
got property investors crash course in
September so by then I'm gonna be
hopefully you know in a much better
place so I'm gonna be there come come
what may this is regardless of how I'm
feeling I'm gonna be there and I'm gonna
deliver so book yourself on September
I'd look for to meeting you in person
and yeah have an absolutely wonderful
week god bless scene
time thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time